we're not actively rooting for any of
these movies to fail but there's
something about each of them that
carries a whiff of an inevitable bomb we
may be wrong birth thankfully purrs when
that the studio executives whose job
depends on these turkeys turning a
profit here are our predictions for the
biggest box-office bombs of 2020 Matthew
McConaughey's career rebirth dubbed them
a connaissance
that's been good for the actor and great
for film and TV fans however despite the
praise box office results and even an
Academy Award win for Dallas buyers club
this is still the same guy who recently
signed on to star in serenity the beach
bum and the Dark Tower death always wins
that's the deal
McConaughey has comfor but he's still
prone to headlining duds and the
forthcoming the gentlemen looks to be
one of them with Guy Ritchie at the helm
McConaughey leads a stacked cast
including Charlie Hunnam Colin Farrell
and Hugh Grant the British American
co-production is about two British drug
lord who tries to sell his empire to a
dynasty of Oklahoma billionaires sounds
good but in addition to McConaughey
spotty box office there's a release date
January 24th 2020 just one week after
Doolittle and bad boys for life a movie
doesn't have to be high-profile to be a
bomb take a run for example it's
scheduled for release on January 24 2020
and we barely know a thing about it we
don't even have a trailer for it all we
know is it stars Sarah Paulson and it's
about a teenage girl who has been raised
in total isolation by her mother and
then discovers that a mother has been
hiding a sinister secret that makes it
sound like it could be interesting
especially since is created by the team
that made the underrated searching and
fortunately there's been almost no
promotion behind it which would seem to
indicate that Lionsgate doesn't have
much confidence in the film and has
tried to quietly unload it during one of
the winter dump months Lionsgate has had
a very successful 2019 with John wick
three so maybe they just want runs of
quietly saunter away while they plot
their next to blockbuster
long live the king select the Hedgehog
crashing and burning seems guaranteed at
this point but what else can you expect
from reaction to the first trailer was
so bad it was such a mess that director
Jeff Fowler pledged to redesign the
character to please funds this massive
undertaking push the film back from his
original release date of November 8 2019
to February 14 2020 and no doubt added
some zeros to his reported 90 million
dollar budget with that costly redesign
it's harder to wonder what the Paramount
should have taken a loss on a modest
turd instead of the massive bomb were
now expecting with a few notable
exceptions video game adaptations aren't
exactly blessed with a great track
record when it comes to box office
performance Sonic the Hedgehog seems
unlikely to fix that in fact we expect
the fastest singer land to speed right
out of theaters within a few weeks
fantasy island was a cheesy 1970s TV
show starring Ricardo Montalban as the
host of a magical island resort 2020s
Fantasy Island is a big-screen update
starring Michael Pena which based on the
trailer turns the resort into a torture
paradise similar to movies like saw and
hostile the studio behind the movie plum
house has more or less earned our trust
over the years but turning a 1970s TV
hits into a gory horror movies seems
like a stretch it's difficult to imagine
fans of the original show turning out
for this while modern horror fans seem
very unlikely to even be familiar with
the source material fantasy island a
separate lease on February 14 2020 so
maybe it'll satisfy young lovers
bloodlust by showing pretty people
getting hacked to pieces over
Valentine's weekend though with the
recent success of supernatural and
highbrow horror films like it follows a
quiet place and hereditary we can't help
but wonder if there's even an audience
for this type of torture driven horror
anymore even if there is or fantasy
island be the movie that they show up in
droves for comic book movies are often
big business at the box office but most
of those hits have come from Marvel or
DC a march 13 2020 Sony is taking a risk
on a less well-known character from
Valiant Comics named bloodshot in blood
shots a murdered soldier seeks revenge
after being reanimated with superpowers
bloodshot's has the ability to heal
instantly and he's seeking vengeance
against those who killed him before he
was rebirth by an evil corporation
basically he's like a mix between
Captain America
The Punisher Wolverine and Robocop
despite having a pretty effective
trailer
there's nothing about bloodshot that
screams must-see and the summer 2019
thoughts s if your blockbuster movie is
a must-see moviegoers won't bother
especially with so many other
entertainment options out there Sony may
be hoping that star Vin Diesel will make
up for bloodshot's lack of name
recognition but despite being 2017 top
grossing actor diesels box office has
mostly predicated on playing alongside
an ensemble as he does in The Fast and
the Furious franchise and guardians of
the galaxy
well bloodshot looks likely to bomb
Diesel can take solace knowing Fast and
Furious 9 will be coming else a few
months later with his friends I don't
have friends I got family we predicted
that the New Mutants would bomb in 2019
and then it was too late into 2020 who
saw that coming
but everything we said still holds true
the New Mutants was originally scheduled
to be released on April 13 2018 but was
pushed back to August 2nd 2019 following
Disney's purchase of Fox it was pushed
back again this time to April 3rd 2020
it doesn't help that the x-men franchise
is in a bad way following Dark Phoenix
the final film in the previous trilogy
and the biggest bomb in the series even
under the best of circumstances it would
be hard for the New Mutants to follow
that at this point the studio might be
better served cutting their losses
dropping their new mutants on the disney
plus and crossing their fingers as says
the new mutants Mesa past Dark Phoenix
his record is a financial low point in
the x-men franchise on the bright side
at least nobody is expecting anything
different Disney had one of the most
successful years ever in 2019 but
Artemis Fowl doesn't feature Jedi
Knights Marvel superheroes or CG
animated characters from Disney classics
it's a Disney branded live-action film
that has more in common with Disney's
other live-action movies which don't
tend to be quite as groundbreaking
Tomorrowland only made 209 million
dollars worldwide on a one hundred and
ninety million dollar budget in 2015 a
wrinkle in time mustard a measly 132
million dollars in 2018 against a 103
million dollar budget the Nutcracker and
the four realms made a mere 173 million
dollars worldwide against the one
hundred and twenty million dollar budget
even the one successful Pirates of the
Caribbean franchise is a sinking ship
Artemis Fowl is following in these
footsteps
and may do even worse based on the
best-selling novel series the film
follows a young genius criminal
mastermind who becomes locked in an epic
battle against evil fairies Disney
probably hoped that this story would be
as Harry Potter and it certainly seems
packed with fantasy and franchise
potential however the house of mouse
moved Artemis Fowl back from its
original August 29 team release to the
more competitive summer date of May 29th
that could mean that the studio is
feeling confidence or that it hopes to
just get it out of the way in the early
summer one way or another does he may
have to sell a lot of baby yoda
merchandise to make up for the money
Artemis Fowl seems likely to lose for
the second time in four years moviegoers
will be getting a new Ghostbusters movie
ironic considering we had to wait 27
years for a new Ghostbusters in 2016
fans didn't show up for that one which
made a hefty yet disappointing two
hundred and twenty nine million dollars
worldwide against the 144 million dollar
budget numbers like that mean one thing
in Hollywood no sequel Ghostbusters
afterlife isn't a sequel to the 2016
Ghostbusters but to the 1984 original
well details are sketchy the new
Ghostbusters will essentially be the
third film and the original Ghostbusters
franchise with Bill Murray dan Aykroyd
Sigourney Weaver Annie Potts and Ernie
Hudson reprising their roles joining
their ranks are Paul Rudd one of the
most bankable names in comedy with
Academy Award nominated director jason
reitman son of original Ghostbusters
director Ivan Reitman taking the reins
so why does this like a bomb
well film fans are fickle 31 years have
passed since the last film in this
timeline Ghostbusters 2 was released to
poor reviews in 1989
is there still a huge audience there
maybe Ghostbusters seems like a beloved
franchise has been passed down through
the generations but the same could be
said about terminator inseminator to
terminator dark fate released in 2019 as
a direct sequel probably killed the
franchise Ghostbusters afterlife could
meet a similar fate on July 10th Eddie
Murphy was huge at his peak in addition
to saving Saturday Night Live his
starring role in Beverly Hills Cop saw
the film opening more theaters
nationwide than Indiana Jones and
Ghostbusters in 1984
what's more Beverly Hills Cop wound up
topping both in total final grosses
that's an incredible achievement but
that was also 35 years ago despite
receiving some of the best reviews of
his career for Dolomites as my name in
2019
Eddie Murphy is a long way away from his
box office glory days that said he's
hoping to change that with a sequel to
one of his biggest box-office hits from
that's era 1988 coming to America in the
original Murphy plays a pampered African
prince who goes into cover in Queens to
find a wife
the original was a massive success
earning returns of 288 million dollars
worldwide those would be huge numbers
for a comedy today but can coming to
America come even close to flying that's
high when it arrives on August 7th it
seems doubtful for one there's a time
factor 32 years with a Parsons coming to
America first graced our screens there's
also the fact that Murphy's box office
clouds has been trending downwards for a
while Prince Akeem returns
sadly seems likely to continue that
trend on December 18 2021 a brothers
hopes to mine holiday season box-office
gold with an adaptation of Frank
Herbert's beloved book series dune dune
has sold millions of copies and maybe
the greatest sci-fi novel of all time
but all of that has very little to do
with how successful the film adaptation
is particularly during the end of the
year His Dark Materials with a pretty
popular fantasy novel series of the
Golden Compass barely broke even in 2007
mortal engines sold plenty of books but
the film couldn't sell tickets and
bombed big time and do we even need to
mention John Carter based on the Edgar
Rice Burroughs Barsoom stories John
Carter is one of the biggest bombs ever
for every Lord of the Rings Harry Potter
or Game of Thrones there are numerous
other sci-fi and fantasy stories that
should have stayed on the printed page
this isn't the first time Turner's been
on the big screen either David Lynch's
dune died a horrible death in 1984
earning 30 million dollars worldwide
against a 40 million dollar budget
here's the new dune director that evil
nerves last movie Blade Runner 2049
tanked in 2017 high-concept sci-fi is
always risky and dooms box office seems
over certain to like spice check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]